[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello martin
i knew it was going
hello walter hi
are you doing well
why do you always ask that i need to
know
why do you need to know
it's important for the viewers
you really think so
my dad used to always ask me are you
just asking because of a
repetition or do you ask because you
care
okay so i came someone else asked you
want the short version or the long
version
or the other one is i've got no new
complaints
okay okay
so let's open with a word of prayer then
get into this
our heavenly father thank you for giving
us the opportunity to do these discus
discussions
we thank you and we ask your blessing
and your guidance in jesus name amen
amen
martin if we ever lose our sense of
humor i think we will be doomed
because some things you can survive only
with a sense of humor
right that's true
now last time we spoke about elijah
and we spoke about the second elijah
but there's a third elijah
and there's a remnant
so let's have a look at some of these
elijahs
and
continue our discussion yeah with regard
to them and it's important to know that
this is now for our time
yes we cannot
put all of this into the realms of
history
and continue as though these things were
but they don't affect us at all yeah
because a lot of people would love to do
that then your bible might as well be a
dead letter
so we're going to talk about the third
elijah the 144 000 and the double
portion
now when we go to the book of revelation
chapter 14
and uh this is of course the chapter
which contains the three angels messages
and i looked low
elam stood on mount zion and with him
000 having his father's name written in
their foreheads
in other words they had the character
restored that god had placed originally
in adam
[Music]
that's what it means to have his
character written in your cognitive
function
and i heard a voice from heaven as the
voice of many waters and as a voice of a
great thunder and i heard the voice of
harper's harping with their
and they sung as it were a new song
before the throne and before the four
beasts and the elders and no man could
learn that song but 144 000
which were redeemed from the earth so we
know who they are
they are redeemed
we don't know
exactly
what persons we are referring to
and when it comes to the 144 thousandths
silence is golden
so our wish should be to be part of the
144 000 or to stand with them that's it
that's as far as we can go
and that stand with them it's an
important
verse yes or sentence
that's interesting
that this is a new song
but we know that it's also an old song
so it's a new song that has a new an old
song that has a new twist
now when israel was redeemed miriam led
them in a song
but that wasn't the song of the lamb no
no
and
it was sung with gusto and it was the
song of moses
because moses was a type of the
deliverer
but only those
that have been associated with the lamb
that was slain will be able to sing this
song
these are they which were not defiled
with women
for they are
virgins
in other words they weren't defiled with
the false ideologies of churches
these are they which follow the lamb
whether so ever he goeth
these were redeemed from amongst men
being the first fruits unto god and the
lamb
so this is a wonderful text we have
quite a
bit of detail here
we know that they keep themselves pure
from the wine of babylon
that means they must have discernment
right yes they must have that name of
the father written in their photos and
they must reflect his character that
means they must have the law written in
their heart that's it otherwise you
won't be able to say that right
because he who turns his foot from the
law even his prayers and abomination
that's true that's what the bible says
and later on here
when you get to the three angels
messages
it totally shows you the adherence to
the law you have to to be part of this
and in their mouth was found no guile
reminds me of nathaniel
in their mouth was found no guile for
they are without fault before the throne
of god now the only way you can be
without fault before the throne of god
is if you were washed
in the blood of the lamb that's it and
you've got this righteousness covering
you yes
so
this is a description of
the
remnant
and i saw another angel fly in the midst
of heaven having the everlasting gospel
to preach unto them that dwell on the
earth and to every nation and kindred
and tongue and people
a very important
issue is that the remnant that brings
the final message must be a universal
remnant can't be a local one
and they say with a loud voice fear god
and give glory to him for the hour of
judgment is come
and worship him that made heaven and
earth and the sea and the fountains of
water there you have the seal of god
they announced the time of judgment has
come
and the only reference that we have in
that of that we find it in the book of
daniel
when it comes to the 2
300 days
and then there was another angel and
that one was saying babylon has fallen
it's fallen the great city
because she made all the nations drink
of the wine of the wrath of a
fornication
so the 144 thousand
did they imbibe in this cup no
no
so it's very important that you
understand what's in that cup
and that you refuse to drink it
true
and then there's the third angel which
also says with a loud voice if any man
worship the beast and his image and
receive his mark in his forehead or in
his hand
the same shall drink of the wine of the
wrath of god which is poured out without
mixture into the cup of his indignation
mixture with what
there's no grace
no
so this is
indignation
no longer mingled with grace this is the
same as
the days of noah
you either
receive the robe of righteousness
or you don't
and if you don't
then you get the cup of his indignation
which is god's
retributive action
and he shall be tormented with fire and
brimstone in the presence of the holy
angels and in the presence of the lamb
so they will be consumed by his
brightness by his holiness
fire and brimstone they will be
as sodom and gomorrah
so this is a
terrible verse
and that is something that the world
needs to understand because we are
at the point of its fulfillment
so let's go to the elijah message
which is exactly the same thing as the
three angels messages correct it is
preparing the way
for jesus second coming
now when elijah spoke
on mount carmel
did it include a judgment yes
they had to make a decision choose ye
this day choose thee this day
and if they made the wrong decision
they
suffered the consequences
and the prophets of baal
they were executed
there was no mercy
they were all
executed
and it had to do with the commandments
of god
so the third angel's message
deals with
the commandments of god and the
authority of god because the seal of god
is in there
worship him who made the heavens the
earth the sea and the springs of water
and that we find in the fourth
commandment
so it's all very
intertwined and logical
now the elijah message in this age just
prior to the second coming of christ and
the clouds of heaven god calls for men
who will prepare a people to stand in
the great day of the lord
prepare a people to stand
does this mean this is a message to the
outside to every tribe and nation and
king yes
but also to insight yes it's a it's a
universal message it cuts all ways right
and it starts off with the are of his
judgment has come
and it refers to the everlasting gospel
in other words it points us towards
salvation in christ right
and then it tells us about the wine of
babylon
now one is doctrine so therefore
this message must expose false doctrine
did elijah expose false doctrine yes he
exposed all those false bill priests
exactly and he showed that their
religion
was based on or had a foundation of sand
okay
and then there was a third message
which takes us back to the commandments
of god
and the mark of the beast and we know
the beast is because the reformation
identified it for us
and even prior to the reformation there
were
pre-reformers that showed us exactly who
the beast was it is the system of
catholicism the second elijah john the
baptist
also
worked against false doctrine correct
and disobedience
so the lord is giving messengers to his
people through the instruments he has
chosen and he would have all heed the
admonition and warnings he sends
the message preceding the public
ministry of christ was repent publicans
and sinners repent pharisees and
sadducees
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand our
message is not to be one of peace and
safety as a people who believe in christ
soon appearing we have a definite
message to bear
this is very important so the message
goes to publicans it goes to sinners
but it also goes to the pharisees and
the sadducees it goes to the church
and the leaders in the church everybody
is affected nobody is excluded
let's continue with this quote from
testimonies for the church volume 3
those whom god has chosen for an
important work have ever been received
with distrust and suspicion let's just
stop there
so you bring this message
what will be your lot you're always
unpopular and you're always blamed for
everything and you
so there will be distrust and suspicion
so what side would you like to be on
those that receive the accolades or
those that receive distrust and
suspicion just trust in suspicion
because it's a safe side to be on right
it's not a comfortable side but it's a
safe side okay
anciently when elijah was sent with a
message from god to the people they did
not heed the warning can we expect
something similar
the bible and history tells us
definitely
they thought him unnecessarily severe
and even thought that he must have lost
his senses because he had denounced them
the favored people of god
he denounced the favored people of god
so will the anti-typical elijah message
just by presenting it to the world also
denounce many in the church definitely
and they will be the accusers
and tell you you're the troublers of
israel all right so what did he denounce
them as as sinners
and their crimes are so aggravated
that the judgments of god would awaken
against them
martin this is very serious because he's
talking to the church
satan and his host have ever been
arrayed against those who bear the
message of warning and who reprove sins
the unconsecrated will also be united
with the adversary of souls to make the
work of god's faithful servants as hard
as possible
now
fortunately i've never experienced this
in my life have you martin
well i must admit
i have experienced a lot
okay
well
but you know it's rather comforting
that
this distrust and suspicion
when it does come it is a bit
disconcerting
but at least it shows you
that you are on the right road but
there's a danger as well because you
could become fanatical
yes you have to be aware of all of these
things
so the message is not one of peace and
safety right and the message will
actually cause division
i am come to send fire on the earth and
what will i if it be already kindled
but i have a baptism to be baptized with
and how am i straightened till it be
accomplished
he can't wait
we complain because we have to wait so
long right
suppose he that i'm come to give peace
on earth i tell you nay
but rather division
it's interesting
that the new translations
insert the word divisive
to say that the person who is divisive
is the problem
but jesus was here according to his own
words the most divisive person exactly
to walk on earth because he brought the
vision so it's not the person
that's divisive the message
of jesus
is divisive because it will make you
choose sides it will divide the sheep
from the goats
from henceforth there shall be five in
one house divided three against two and
two against three the father shall be
divided against the son the son against
the father the mother against the
daughter the daughter against the mother
the mother-in-law her daughter-in-law
and the daughter in law against her
mother-in-law
war
in the families
so this is also war inside of the church
absolutely
so we will have this conflict
at every level of society
and anybody who accepts truth will have
to agree
that this is so
there's no way around it
1 john 4 verse 18 says there is no fear
in love
but perfect love casts out fear because
fear has torment he that feareth is not
made perfect in love
so even in spite of all this turmoil
the turmoil is actually
a little guarantee
that you found the right part
now in romans chapter 11 we read i say
then as god cast away his people
god forbid for i also am an israelite of
the seed of abraham of the tribe of
benjamin god has not cast away his
people which he
foreign what he not what the scripture
says of elias
how he maketh intercession to god
against israel saying lord they have
killed thy prophets and dig down thine
altars and i am left alone and they seek
my life
but what says the answer of god unto him
i have reserved to myself seven thousand
men who have not bowed the knee to the
image of baal
even so then at this present time also
there is a remnant
according to the election of grace
now that applied in paul's day
and still applies to this day
does it apply to the remnant for sure it
even it comes from elijah's time all
right now how did elijah feel
discouraged he was down in the dumps and
he thought he was the only one
right and he wanted to give up and then
he was told no you're not the only one
there are seven thousand
now if i was elijah i would ask the lord
why are they so silent
why don't i hear them you got this
you've got the 50 50 in the caves
you've got
with all of this
i can
i can relate to
you asking god
where are they
but these verses they're pretty
encouraging huh
without them without them i don't know i
think i would have despaired by now
so the elijah message is to encircle the
earth
this message was personified in elijah
then in elisha
then in john the baptist
and we know that it will also be there
in a found final light loud cry to the
inhabitants of the world by the remnant
now who are they
it's those that keep the commandments of
god and have the testimony of jesus
christ
so that is the elijah message right and
the three angels message now we had this
verse and the last one we will put it
there again behold i will send you
elijah the prophet before the coming of
the great and dreadful day of the lord
and he shall turn the hearts of the
fathers to the children and the heart of
the children to their fathers
lest i come and smite the earth with a
curse
now what will
actually achieve this there must be two
things
as far as i'm concerned
the one is the message
must do its work and the holy spirit
must intercede
but mankind is so stubborn
and your own family is also so stubborn
that the message alone just won't do it
so maybe the earth must be
smitten with a bit of a curse
so that people can come to their senses
and start thinking and start putting two
and two together
rather than sweeting sweeping two and
two under the rug right
now if we make a comparison we look at
the miracles of elijah the prophet
elijah prophesied a drought
and it was a three and a half year
drought
the meal and the oil that multiplied the
child that he restored to life the
sacrifice consumed by fire on mount
carmel
the captains and men that were slain by
fire
the rain
that he finally prayed for that came
and the waters of the jordan were
divided
and then we have some interesting things
about elijah he was fed three times by
the direct intervention of god he was
fed by ravens
he was fed by the widow
and the meal and the oil
never
stopped producing
and he was fed by an angel who backed
him a cake
with which he was able to run for 40
days yeah
yes
now that's very interesting
so can we expect
that the anti-typical elijah
will also be fed
by god's circumstances definitely and
then he might even be fed by a widow
sometimes you
you find information
[Music]
from the widow that is quite sublime
that's it
and
that you will be fed by angels
will angels surround those
and camp around those that fear him it's
a promise and will they enlighten you
and help you in your bible study
if you sincerely seek will you not fight
that is where the crux lies
you must seek it and allow god to help
that's what must happen right if you
don't do that
he cannot because he is a gentleman yes
now if we expand this list a little bit
of these miracles
and we include some things which you
know might not be
as miraculous as the crucible of oil
never failing or the meal
but
then we actually get to according to
some studies to 14 things
elijah he caused the rain to cease for
three and a half years
he was fed by ravens which is actually a
miracle he didn't perform what god did
but it's part of his life
miracles of the barrel of meal and crews
of oil resurrection of the widow's son
calling a fire from heaven on the altar
then causing it to rain
the prophecy that ahab's sons would all
be destroyed was fulfilled the prophecy
that jezebel would be eaten by dogs the
prophecy that ahaziah would die of his
illness
calling fire from heaven upon the first
fifty soldiers calling fire from heaven
upon the second fifty soldiers
parting the jordan prophecy that elijah
should have a double portion of his
spirit
and being caught up to heaven in a
whirlwind
that's quite an experience right
can the antitypical elijah
expects similar things
i think so yes
can we expect to be fed by very unusual
circumstances
yes i've experienced that in my life
okay can we experience that the battle
of meal and the cruise of oil
just constantly produces even when you
are in dire straits definitely i've had
that in my life can we have spiritual
resurrections of widow's sons
that's caused by evangelism isn't it
amazing
calling fire from heaven on the altar
can we ask for the outpouring of the
holy spirit
have you experienced it in a meeting
and then it suddenly started to rain
people accept it
and
can we say that certain people will be
destroyed
can we say that jezebel will be eaten by
dogs
you just have to read your bible
and then you will know and all of these
things
now
i don't wish to call fire from heaven to
kill the 50
50 soldiers but why were they killed
they were arrogant
come down king's calling you get on with
it
gone
the final one that came
he came extremely apologetic
but it took two times
amazing so only the third time
was there no fire from heaven there are
three angels messages
if you ignore the first one and the
second one and the third one you'll be
in big trouble
can we expect the jordan to part
god will do it for us but you have to
put your foot in the jordan exactly
and then can we ask for a double portion
yes we will need it right
and is there a possibility that the
anti-typical elijah can be caught up to
heaven in a whirlwind definitely we've
read it in revelation
144 thousands okay
now let's go to elisha
elisha was to bear the same message as
elijah
but he was going to have double the
impact i mean you can't do a greater
miracle than raise the widow's son
right
but elisha was to have a double portion
and the bible is so interesting
when you study this second kings chapter
2 from verse 9
and it came to pass when they were gone
over that elijah said unto elisha
ask what i shall do for thee
before i be taken away from thee and
elisha said i pray thee let a double
portion of thy spirit be upon me
he could have asked for anything but he
asked for that
does it remind you of solomon
yes he asked for it
for the wisdom
and he received it right
now elisha asked for a double portion
obviously he realized
that he would need it
so can we ask for a double portion i
think it's necessary
will it be given to us if we don't ask
you have to ask
ask and you shall receive right
and he said thou hast asked the hard
thing nevertheless if thou see me when i
am taken from thee it shall be so unto
thee but if not it shall not be so
does that mean it's our thing for elijah
to give it or for elijah to receive it
i think it cuts both ways and
elijah in any way could do nothing it
had to be god god
so it has to do with a message
why does elijah need a double portion
and came to pass
as they still went on and talked that
behold they appeared a chariot of fire
and horses of fire and parted them both
the sunday and elijah went up by a world
wind into heaven and elisha saw it that
means he got the double portion
and he cried my father my father the
chariot of israel and the horsemen
thereof and he saw him no more
and he took hold of his own clothes and
rent them in two pieces
and he took up also the mantle of elijah
that fell from him
and went back and stood by the bank of
jordan
he realized that he won't be able to do
anything with his old clothes he needed
a new mantle
and this mantle
was the prophetic mantle and then in a
sense it must represent the
righteousness of christ as well
so elijah must have a rob of
righteousness otherwise he wouldn't have
gone up without seeing death right
jesus jesus's righteousness must have
covered him so we all need that mantle
exactly and if you have that mantle
can you qualify for a double portion if
you need it yes
so if we go to the miracles in the
ministry of elisha
we see the parting of the jordan the
healing of the waters the curse of the
she-bears
that's an interesting one
when the young people came out and they
said you baldy
watch it
you qualify one
yeah you could say that and
then the she-bears came and it was a
lesson
that you don't mess with the elijah
message
you have to be very careful you could
just have a confrontation with a
she-bear that's it
filling up the valley with water
deception of the moabites with the
valley of blood miracle of the vessels
of oil prophecy that the shunammite
woman would have a son resurrection of
the shunammite sun healing of the guards
miracle of the bread healing of name and
perception of gehazi's transgression
cursing gehazi with leprosy floating of
the axe head prophecy of the syrian
battle plans vision of the chariots
smiting the syrian army with blindness
restoring the sight of the syrian army
prophecy of the end of the great famine
this is by the way very interesting
smiting the syrian army with blindness
and then restoring their sight
and then feeding them
giving them food and drink
is that our job definitely
feeding them will be with the gospel
absolutely prophecy of the end of the
great famine prophecy that the scoffing
noblemen would see but not partake of
the abundance deception of the sirians
with the sound of the chariot
prophecy of the seven year famine that's
double
previously it was three and a half right
prophecy of ben haddad's
untimely death
hazal's cruelty to israel the prophecy
that jehu would smite the house of ahab
the prophecy that joash would smite the
syrians that
affect prophecy that joash would smite
syria thrice but not consume it
and the resurrection of the man touched
by his bones even in his death it's a
modern that's a double portion that's 28
as opposed to 14.
bible is fascinating huh
extraordinary
and
it's a promise
for us as well that's what makes it so
alive
can you be any
greater than elijah who was taken up to
heaven no obviously not right yeah
so let's say that the attacks against
god's people will be severe and we need
a double portion
before the great disappointment there
were 50 000 millerites
and after the disappointment there were
50.
a scary statistic
right
it's 50 out of 50 000
and the message was behold the
bridegroom cometh after the great
disappointment the remnant was entrusted
with the three angels messages
so these 50
formed the kernel
of the new movement
that had to be prepared to spread the
three angels messages that's it the
purified movement because
if we read that whole story in the
history
god purposed this to happen yes now
people will say well look at this this
is really a great disappointment and
it's pathetic that you went from 50 000
to 50.
but these 50 refused to accept that that
which they had experienced and that
which they had studied
was all based on falsehood
they were not moved and these 50 were
then enabled to receive greater light
it's the same that happened to the
disciples did they need a double portion
definitely
in order to stand right
so the message of john the baptist was a
new and startling message this comes
from the review and herald
and could not be interwoven with
superstitions and traditions of the
pharisees
the disciples of john were not to think
that his self-denial his self-sacrifice
his prayers his devotions his fastings
were like those of the pharisees
the pharisees fastest in hypocrisy and
there was no vitality in their religious
exercises
to seek to blend the pretense of the
pharisees with the devotion of john
would be only to make evident the breach
between them the work of john
was to expose the character
of the works of the pharisees to set
their traditions and heresies in their
true light before the people
that's an important work
so he had a very important work of
exposing
the church of god
the the falsehoods inside of it
so is that part of the elijah message
then that is
is it a comfortable one no can you
expect backlash oh definitely
can you expect name calling
and all of those previous attributes
that we saw that people might start
pointing towards you
so in 1844 you had the great
disappointment
there was a scattering
they were mocked
they were derided they were publicly
mocked they were mocked in literature
they were mocked from the pulpits
and you had a gathering
a falling away
and then eventually a remnant of the
memorand which was a final gathering
and there was a message to be preached
and they received a double portion
suddenly the scriptures became a living
reality
they discovered the sanctuary message
law and grace the relationship between
it
creation
councils on health
the sabbath the investigative judgment
the second coming and the millennium the
truths about daniel and revelation
now some of these truths
were there before
martin luther had discovered many of
them
and had rejected some of them
right like the sabbath for example
was he confronted with it yes absolutely
carl stutt confronted him so there were
many
and there was the question of baptism
and all of these issues
so we will have to maintain our position
amidst the severest attacks and ridicule
by the world's great men
but the pillars will have to be
maintained these are not negotiable
that is
100 what we must realize
there's no compromise no negotiation on
these no they have been established by
the spirit of god they are in harmony
with the scripture
and
there's no way that you can move any of
these pillars no matter how much you try
and you can also not put them
in history and say it's not applicable
today
they must be applicable to the end of
time that's it
so 1 john 2 verse 24 applies to these
pillars let that therefore abide in you
which you have heard from the beginning
if that which you have heard from the
beginning shall remain in you
you ye also shall continue in the son
and in the father they are immovable
first selected messages when the power
of god testifies as to what is truth
that truth is to stand forever as the
truth
are they attempts to tear down the
pillars lots
continually right continually
no after suppositions contrary to the
light god has given or to be entertained
are they entertained yep constantly
right
men will arise with interpretations of
scripture which are to them truth but
which are not truth
the truth for this time god has given us
as a foundation for our faith he himself
has taught us what is truth
one will arise and still another with
new light which contradicts the light
god has given under the demonstration of
the holy spirit a few are still alive
this was at the time when this was
written
who passed through the experience gained
in the establishment of this truth
god has gracially spared their lives to
repeat and repeat till the close of
their lives the experience through which
they passed even as did john the apostle
till the very close of his life
and the standard bearers who have fallen
in debt or to speak through the
reprinting of their writings
i'm instructed that thus that their
voices are to be heard
they are to bear their testimony as to
what constitutes the truth for this time
we are not to receive the words of those
who come with a message that contradicts
the special points of our faith that's a
pretty straight
message right
this is relating to
inside of the church
and to those outside now how often when
you quote one of the pioneers
do the theologians jump onto a bandwagon
and condemn what the pioneers have
written
we've had quite a few of that
the leadings of the lord were mocked and
most wonderful ways revelations of what
is truth point of the point was
established by the god of heaven
that which was truth then
is truth today but the voices do not
cease to be heard this is truth i have
new light but these new lights in
prophetic lines are manifest in
misapplying the word
and setting the people of god adrift
without an anchor to hold them
if the student of the word would take
the truths which god has revealed in the
leadings of his people and appropriate
these truths
digest them and bring them into our
practical life they would then be living
channels of light
but those who have set themselves to
study out new theories have a mixture of
truth and error combined
and after trying to make these things
prominent have demonstrated that they
have not kindled their taper from the
divine altar and it has gone out in
darkness
one i'm afraid that many of our colleges
have actually kindled tapers from
another source
because they want to change the pillars
and they are teaching new things
they've totally
denigrated some of the pillars not even
try to try to
what amazes me is that we tolerate them
well
that amazes me as well titus 1 9 holding
fast the faithful word as it has been
taught that he may be able by sound
doctrine both to exhort and convince the
gainsayers
speak thou the things which become sound
doctrine and in all things showing
ourselves the pattern of good works in
doctrine showing uncorruptness gravity
sincerity sound speech that cannot be
condemned that he that is of the
contrary part may be ashamed having no
evil thing to say of you
martin it's all there in the scriptures
and we are just repeating history
read
make sure it's in the scriptures
when it's in the scriptures
and it's in harmony with what the
prophets have said
then buy it apply it eat it
live it
now one of the points of contention
is
that it is a conspiracy theory to say
that the papacy is the beast that is
going to implement the mark of the beast
or see to it that it is implemented by
his cronies
and that this issue will be a prominent
issue at the time of the end
that part is also very prevalent now
that it's
for our time it might have been like
this
in the 1800s but it's no longer like
this i've seen article after article
written by prominent people presidents
union presidents you name it uh along
these lines
not to speak of theologians they are
like grapes on a bunch
so let's just make sure the papacy is
just what prophecy declared that she
should be the apostasy of the latter
times
it is part of her policy to assume the
character which will best accomplish her
purpose but beneath the variable
appearance of the chameleon she conceals
the invariable venom of the serpent
faith ought not to be kept with heretics
nor persons suspected of heretics then
she quotes the source
she declares
shall this power
whose record for a thousand years is
written in the blood of the saints be
now acknowledged as part of the church
of christ
it is not without reason that the claim
has been put forth in protestant
countries that catholicism differs less
widely from protestantism than in former
times
there has been a change but the change
is not in the papacy
catholicism indeed resembles much of the
protestatism that now exists
because protestantism has so greatly
degenerated since the days of the
reformers
that's interesting right so modern if
you deny
this statement
don't you then dump the second angel and
the third angel's message in the waste
paper basket exactly then you have to
concoct
all sorts of things to
say how it's not relevant or it's not
the same anymore it's not even the
interpretation has to be done but only
applied to the past and it doesn't apply
to the present
can you call yourself a seventh-day
adventist if you don't believe this no
so
doesn't rome itself acknowledge that
exactly doesn't rome say that if you
cease to believe that the papacy is the
antichrist then you cannot be a
seventh-day adventist doesn't she say
that herself
those direct words in those direct words
and yet we have theologian upon
theologian who will deny the very basics
that we have of here right
so everything that martin luther stood
for everything that he fought for is
swept under the table because rome has
changed
no
protestantism has changed
the time is upon us when the miracle
working of the archdeceiver will be more
decidedly revealed and his deceptions
will increase
in that elusive attraction
so that they will perplex and if
possible deceive the very elect martin
if this is the case do we need a double
portion we you we will not be able to
stand if we don't ask and
receive a double portion
okay the prince of darkness with his
evil angels is working upon the
christian world
inducing those who profess the name of
christ to stand under the banner of
darkness to make war with those who keep
the commandments of god and have the
faith of jesus is that a conspiracy or
is that a fact that's a fact and a
promise
an apostate church
will unite with the powers of earth and
hell
to place upon the forehead or in the
hand the mark of the beast and prevail
upon the children of god to worship the
beast and his image
they will seek to compel them to
renounce their allegiance to god's law
and yield homage to the papacy and the
sad thing is who's going to be their
greatest agents
leaders in our own church
fallen leaders in our own church yeah
and they're going to be doing it with
rousing messages that
tickles the ear
and make you think that they stand in
one position when actually something
else is being done
then we'll come the times which will try
men's souls for the confederacy of
apostasy will demand
that the loyal subjects of god shall
renounce the law of jehovah and
repudiate the truth of his word
then will the gold be separated from the
dross and it will be made apparent who
are the godly
who are the loyal and the true
who are the disloyal the dross and the
tinsel
what clouds of chaff will then be born
away by the fan of god
where now our eyes can discover only
rich floors of wheat
will be chaffed blown away with a fan of
god everyone who is not centered in
christ
will fail to stand the test and ordeal
of that day
while those who are clothed with
christ's righteousness will stand firm
to truth and duty
those who have trusted in their own
righteousness will be arranged under the
banner of the prince of darkness
then it will be seen whether the choice
is for christ or belial it's the same
choice that elijah placed the people
under
those have been self-distrustful
who have been so circumstanced that they
have not dared to face stigma and
reproach
will at last openly declare themselves
for christ and his law
while many who have appeared to be
flourishing trees
but who have borne no fruit
will go with the multitude to do evil
and will receive the mark of apostasy in
the forehead or in the hand
this is a prophecy is it going to be
fulfilled definitely
you know in the bible it states that the
second beast
will be
speaking
as a dragon it's a lamb speaking as a
dragon
but i think we have to be very careful
for the dragon that's speaking as a lamb
yes i think there are some dragons that
speak like lambs very nice sermons
conservative sermons
but if you go and see what else is going
on
then you see the opposite some troubling
water
now martin
there is a warning
and a promise
in this text
and this should be very encouraging
it says here that those who have been
self-distrustful
who have been so circumstanced that they
have not dared to face stigma and
reproach
will at last openly declare themselves
for christ and his law
in other words there are many people out
there
who are studying these things
listening to the messages of the three
angels but they haven't taken a step to
come forward
but when the time comes
they
will make a decision that's the one side
and then the opposite of that is while
many who have appeared to be flourishing
trees
but who have not borne fruit
will go with the multitude to do evil
so even many in the church
as you say
that was speaking like a lamb but where
actually
dragons
will leave the church
and they will receive the mark of
apostasy in the foreign
because they've come to see matters in
the same light
they have drunk of the wine
of babylon
they have imbibed
in its doctrines they've sat in its
economical councils
they have set a table together
consuming the king's vittles
and they see the enemy
rather in their own ranks than outside
this is a very sad state of affairs
and to deal with it
we need a double portion
and god will provide the double portion
and god will
protect
the anti-typical elisha
because the anti-typical elisha bears
whose cloak
elijah's
so he's preaching the elijah message
but why does he need a double portion
because he's going to get more
opposition and his the circumstances are
going to be such that he will not
survive without the double portion
does he need special protection
definitely
because are there people out to get them
are there people out to mock him yep
they better watch out for the she bears
right
correct so he will receive special
protection
so we have to prayerfully consider where
we stand in all of this
because it's a big package
it's a huge package
and it will
it will take a double portion of
miracles to stand
in the time that we are living in that's
it
now in our next one
we will have to start looking at some of
the issues that we are talking about
because it will become apparent why we
need a double portion in the times that
we're living in
because there's a confrontation coming
there's a confrontation coming with the
priests of baal
and that confrontation takes place
within the church
exactly
so god will have to
help the antitypical elijah
and he will have to supply him with a
double portion
and we will have to stand under the most
unfavorable circumstances
and it is only by the direct
intervention of god
that we will be able to do that
shall we pray we have to
please
heavenly father
we are indeed living in
troubles times
and we need double portion
we need to understand
where we come from
we need to understand what our message
is
and we need to understand
that the message is based on pillars
which were established so as not to be
moved
help us also
not to be moved in jesus name amen
[Music]
you